hi it's so good to see you like another
number one under your belt just like
crazy that's crazy what happens in a
small town yeah not just slow descent
like it's pretty much a year right yeah
it's insane now when you really look at
the lifetime of his finger country radio
and how long it takes to get things at
the chart sometimes so uh yeah it took a
hot minute but it was well worth right
it was like watching that thing grow
like one pointer like oh this is
actually a cute [ __ ] stressful yeah
never a moment where you're like we got
the whole time you're like well we just
I mean we're hoping we're feeling really
good still alive let's keep saying our
prayers like there's never moment even
like to the last week where I can push
week you're like well you never I mean
well let's hope so so yeah when it
finally went off over that finish line
it was a good feeling just celebrate
something like that have you sold me
that I mean I the the day it became
official the band and I were playing a
show in Virginia and I remember walking
up the stage
walking into the green room and my whole
band was like and they were yelling and
like pounding on the walls and I just
broke down crying I mean I have gone to
bed praying so many nights to have a
number one in Canada and then having
number one in the States and to be able
to accomplish both those things you know
within the last couple years it's been
pretty crazy like beyond a success what
does that song mean to you you know the
way what happens in a small town came
about with you know Brantley and his
team reaching out to to my team asking
if I wanted to be a part of it I was
just humbled to be invited to be a part
of such a great song it took me 30
seconds listening into that thing to
know it was such a hit and I feel like
I've gained another older brother in
this life like Brantley and I have
become such good friends we were able to
tour together all year last year and and
so it it it's been like a life-changing
moment yeah I mean it's sad that we
still have this conversation about like
the lack of females getting played on
the radio yeah another was a sad even to
be a featured on us on a song to hit
number one
very rare yeah there seems to be over
the last couple months there seems to be
more talk about that there might be some
change like CMT has said they're gonna
do yeah so do you see now that something
might be happening like it actually
might be being addressed I do I feel
like any industry is cyclical and when
you look back in the 90s there are so
many women on country radio and so I
feel like we are going to have another
time like that and hopefully it's coming
sooner rather than later
I believe that the lack of female
artists right now is it like roots way
back to like the developmental process
with labels with publishers with
songwriting like if we are developing
more female artists then we're recording
and releasing more female artists songs
and then that's gonna trickle down
through radio and and so much and so
forth like the dominoes will fall it's
so cool to see things like CMT you know
changing their programming to 50/50 I
think that's amazing and I think it will
take a bunch of people raising their
hands being like okay this is what we're
gonna do and it's been it's been cool to
see artists do full women tours
festivals do full woman lineups and and
you know I think it's gonna take a bunch
of people raising their hand to slowly
get this gear to turn just see that
tweeted we talked about of a Little Big
Town lady Lady Antebellum the Michigan
radio station said there's no mandate
but you can't play female artists
back-to-back like they were shocked to
hear that you suck there was actual
mandates I mean I mean I've been in this
industry ever since the little girl and
living down Nashville for ten years and
and so I've definitely heard it well we
can't play two females back-to-back and
it's like what I mean in every other
genre you can play a female back-to-back
and if anything that's normal or that's
something you're used to and so I just
don't think it's it's right I don't
think the factual data that those rules
are based on is correct when you go to
country concerts I mean the the
demographic of a country radio audience
is the 34 year old female and when I
look in the crowds of my shows it is 70
to 80 percent female and I'm a female
artist though for the
don't want to listen to female I just
know that's false because then what
would my fan base I mean my fan base
doesn't lie when you look out and see
who are buying tickets to shows so so I
feel like eventually the truth always
comes out and I feel like things are
heading in the right direction what
we're hoping slowly happening we just
need to have patience and you know
people need to keep raising their hand
and doing good things and and hopefully
we'll get we'll get there yeah let's
talk new music okay decided I am I've
been in the studio with mr. Dan huh oh
wow okay has been one of my guitar
players / producer idols ever since I
was growing up and just started playing
and I've always wanted to work with him
and yet I'm so grateful that I've it
hasn't been till this moment of my
career that I've gotten to work with him
because I think I finally know who I am
I know what I want to say I know what I
want to sound like I just released the
first single off this next album my
sophomore album it's called I don't love
you and I'm just I'm super proud of this
new music I can't wait for fans to hear
it it's like the most vulnerable I've
ever gotten on an album I'm talking
about things about my childhood I've
never talked about or is that
nerve-wracking to do oh yeah
and yet at the same time I feel like I'm
at this point in my life I just turned
30 last year and I'm just like okay it's
about to step in
it's about stepping into your own power
and not being ashamed of that and with
that comes being vulnerable with just
your story and everything that's gotten
you to where you are today and what
makes you who you are and so I feel like
if I don't share that full story then
I'm holding back a part of myself yeah
why choose that song as the first single
first introduction to this album I feel
like I have a lot to say in this next
album you know a lot has happened in the
past few years of me you know
celebrating that birthday last year
going through a public breakup going
through all the ups and downs and I
think any time when you go through
something that is like a breakthrough
moment in your life you have to go
through every stage of that grief of
like acceptance denial and
and then getting through to the other
side feeling like that whole newfound
confident and I just felt like I don't
love you was the most real thing I
needed to say right now - you know first
off start this new record to kind of
start this new Plateau it's an outside
song and as a songwriter that's a very
difficult thing for me to do like
someone else wrote do you mean okay and
and yet I love the songwriters in this
town and I will forever put down a flag
for them and be like Nashville has some
of the best songwriters in the world and
if I can lift them up and if I can find
a song that fits my story then I will
definitely record it in in the sleuthing
so I don't love you is the only outside
song on this record but but it was it
just felt like the first right thing
this today yeah like just off the main
strip of Nashville right here
yeah hundreds of artists perform bars
every single day what advice would you
give are just like that that right here
really hustling trying to make trying to
get there break never give up like if
artists are just moving to town or or
even just coming to visit I went back
and forth between Nashville and Canada
for a year and a half every two weeks oh
wow and I didn't really know many people
and I knew one person's name on a piece
of paper actually the first time I came
down to Nashville and I was like I'm
just gonna figure this out I'm gonna
figure out a way to break through and so
I would come down to Nashville and write
songs for two weeks and then I'd go back
to Calgary where I was working a
waitressing job I was going to school
and I was I was digging on the weekend
to make enough money to buy another
plane ticket to come down and I went
back and forth every two weeks and so
yeah I just say the biggest advice is
never stop believing in yourself never
give up and like that little voice that
we listen to sometimes is usually the
right one to listen to yeah and
sonically what is the new album sound
like at this point it sounds like well
my live show sometimes has like more of
like a soul Motown II flare mixed with
country and rock and so this next record
is definitely gonna have a lot of that
it's good
more of a soul like crude fat yeah are
you feeling any kind of pressures last I
was so huge are you feeling any pressure
to follow that up you know they're
always a so much pressure for the
sophomore outwards like this is that
your sophomore album you need to make a
big statement but I'm just excited
that's good I'm so proud of this music
and I know that it's gonna find a voice
wherever it finds a voice and if people
live it
hopefully they love it hopefully
everybody loves it but if they don't
then they should go find music that they
love because life is too short to listen
to music that you don't and so so yeah
I'm just proud of everything everyone